INTO THE MAIN STREAM MEDIA.
WE HAVE REACHED OUT TO HIM FOR
COMMENT AND HE IS AN ANALYST FOR
CNN, CHRIS.
>> Chris: CATHERIN, THANK YOU.
THE HOUSE PASSED A MEASURE
EARLIER TODAY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP MUST SIGN BEFORE
MIDNIGHT TOMORROW TO AVOID
ANOTHER PARTIAL SHUT DOWN.
CHIEF CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MIKE EMMANUEL IS
LIVE ON CAPITOL HILL WITH THE
LATEST WITH WHERE THINGS STAND
RIGHT NOW.
>> Mike: THERE WAS COMPLAINTS
TODAY ABOUT PRICE TAG AND
PROCESS BUT IT IS ONE HURDLE
DOWN AND ONE TO GO.
FACING A FRIDAY NIGHT DEADLINE,
THE HOUSE AND SENATE $1.3
TRILLION PACKAGE TO THE SENATE
FOR CONSIDERATION AFTER THIS
PITCH FROM THE HOUSE SPEAKER.
>> VOTE YES FOR OUR MILITARY.
VOTE YES FOR THE SAFETY AND THE
SECURITY OF THIS COUNTRY.
VOTE YES.
>> Mike: THE SPENDING PACKAGE
INCLUDES ALMOST $655 BILLION FOR
NATIONAL DEFENSE.
NEARLY $48 BILLION FOR HOMELAND
SECURITY, $21 BILLION FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS, AND
ALMOST $1.6 BILLION FOR BARRIERS
AND TECHNOLOGY ON THE BORDER.
THERE WAS PLENTY OF SUPPORT FOR
DEMOCRATS SINCE IT IS A
BIPARTISAN COMPROMISE, BUT THE
HOUSE DEMOCRATIC WHIP HAMMERED
THE GOP FOR VOTING ON IT BEFORE
ANYONE HAD READ THE MORE THAN
2200-PAGE BILL.
>> AS I SAID, NOBODY'S READ THAT
EITHER.
THIS IS REPORT LANGUAGE.
COME TO THE WELL IF YOU'VE READ
THIS LANGUAGE.
>> Mike: IN A LAST-DITCH EFFORT,
THE CONSERVATIVE FREEDOM CAUCUS
APPLIED PRESSURE TO THE RIGHT.
>> PUT A GOOD BILL IN FRONT OF
THE PRESIDENT AND HE'LL SUPPORT
THAT TOO.
I KNOW HE WOULD.
LET'S NOT BRING THE WORST BILL
I'VE SEEN IN MY 10 YEARS IN
CONGRESS TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> Mike: THE WHITE HOUSE SWIFTLY
SHUT DOWN THE ARGUMENT.
>> IS THE PRESIDENT GOING TO
SIGN THE BILL?
THE ANSWER IS YES.
WHY?
BECAUSE IT FUNDS HIS PRIORITIES.
>> Mike: PART OF THE SENATE
LEADER'S PITCH FOR SUPPORT ARE
CONCERNING BACKGROUND CHECKS AND
SAFETY.
>> THIS BILL WILL INCLUDE TWO
IMPORTANT BIPARTISAN COMMON
SENSE MEASURES TO ADDRESS REAL
ISSUES FACING THE NATION.
THE FIX NEXT BILL AND THE STOP
SCHOOL VIOLENCE ACT.
>> Mike: AS FOR WHEN THE SENATE
MIGHT SEND IT TO THE PRESIDENT.
>> THAT DEPENDS.
ONE PERSON, AS YOU KNOW, CAN
SHUT THE PLACE DOWN IF THEY WANT
TO, SO IT'S REALLY UP TO OUR
MEMBERS.
>> Mike: BIPARTISAN SENATE
LEADERSHIP IS EAGER TO VOTE
TONIGHT.
IN FACT, THEY'RE TRYING TO GET
AN AGREEMENT TO VOTE LATER THIS
HOUR.
IT IS POSSIBLE, THOUGH, ONE OR
MORE SENATORS MAY WANT TO MAKE A